so here we are we're in the site where
the skate park is hopefully going to be
constructive very soon skate park in
timnath has been being discussed now for
well over 20 years and in this location
certainly it's been being planned for
nearly three so it's great to be finally
getting here we escaped who've been
working with the youngsters to put
together the plans and the children very
well involved in designing the actual
skate park they want have been asked to
commence construction during the next
few weeks and hopefully it'll be here in
advance of the summer seasons that can
be enjoyed by the local youths as well
as perhaps some of the people who are
here for the summer holidays it's a
perfect setting in many ways it took
completes the circle and provide
something for the slightly older
youngsters in the area to augment what
we've already got with the play area
which is fantastic just slightly to my
right with the water play area and
climbing frames and things and got crazy
golf and all sorts thing so it's great
to have something to fill in this
dismissing link really for the Sabre
slightly more adventurous used in
Timothy it's not a particularly big site
it's it's almost quite understated in
many ways there's a 12 very big skate
and BMX areas nearby and which probably
cater for our Olympic hopefuls this is
more of a sort of a youthful play area
and hopefully it'll be used in good
spirit by everybody it's hopefully still
going to have the same sort of frontage
that does now is certainly not intending
to cage everybody in and I'm sure the
youth and the youngsters of the area
looking forward to arriving as much as I